you have to stick to your guns you have
to find something that you can do
that maybe other people couldn't do i
mean for me
the only sincerity in filmmaking is to
make a film
that you would want to go see yourself
every film you want to be challenging
yourself you want to do something
different
for me cinematically what the spy film
always allowed was
the idea of international travel the
idea of the glamour being able to go
places in the cinema that you'd never be
able to go in real life
the idea that has always fascinated me
about dreams is the realization that
everything within that dream
is created by your own mind i think you
have to be true to your own passion and
your own sense of
what excites you as a storyteller
i think really the only useful advice i
ever got
in terms of you know trying to figure
out your way
in to the film business of film industry
is to
get yourself a script and hang on to it
um
it's that idea that screenplay
that that concept you know whatever
that's going to be that's so important
and
you have to stick to your guns you have
to find something that you can do
that maybe other people couldn't do and
even if that seems different or doesn't
fit into
people's expectations that's what's
going to distinguish it if you can do it
successfully
so i think it's really about sticking to
your guns
and you know doing something you
passionately believe in
rather than uh trying to appeal
to some desire that you imagine other
people have for what they want to see in
a film
i think you have to be true to your own
passion and your own sense of what
excites you as a storyteller you have to
play to your strengths you have to do
something that really excites you
and whatever's different about that in
the case of following the non-linear
structure was a
somewhat unusual choice um but it's
those things that are the strength of
the project
uh it's the things that you can bring to
what you're doing or bring to the
filmmaking craft that maybe not
everybody else is doing
maybe not everybody else can do or has
thought to do that's what's going to
distinguish
the thing so it might seem in some ways
more difficult or seem like something
that would make the project more
difficult to
to sell when it's finished you know what
what have you but for me
i think the answer was definitely to try
to play to my strengths and the things
that i
personally was passionate about but but
very much at the time
i felt very young and very inexperienced
i felt that
my own life and the things i saw in the
world were not going to be of interest
to people
but they felt interesting to me and so i
was looking for a language i was looking
for a genre in which i could take
things that i was interested in and make
them accessible make them interesting to
other people
and i think that the crime genre the
filmmaker and i think that's the way it
works it's
characters are defined through action
double cross things they're doing to
each other
your particular fears about whatever it
is your life your relationships or
whatever those things are
the best filmoir has always been very
firmly founded on
on those relatable fears i think working
in
in films today it's an era where people
tend to watch films more than once even
if they don't like them
you know you'll see it in the cinema on
its first release perhaps and then
you'll see it on
you know cable television television
you're watching an airplane or in a
hotel room or something uh or
winds up eventually on on regular tv
and so i think my generation of
filmmakers
understood where there's a
responsibility to try and
make something that has layers something
that has
more to it the second time you see it or
some different aspect to it
and i chose to take the path
of incorporating that desire
for a layered approach into the
narrative itself into the story if you
like and so i've made films that
have some ambiguity to them or some
layering to them narratively
so that if you see them a second time
you're going to watch them in slightly
different way
and that was that was my approach there
are other filmmakers who approached it
from a purely
visual point of view where they would
just create very dense visuals that
would sustain multiple viewings because
you'd sort of see more in the frame
and so the structure i settled on is one
that
it's based on a musical structure called
the shepherd tone which is a
musical illusion whereby you can keep
climbing up the scale
it's something i'd used in my schools
like the david julian school for the
prestige was the first time we
experimented with it
so you're continually going up the scale
going up the scale but you never seem to
go
out of out of reach if you like and i
wanted to try and apply that
to screenwriting to a narrative and say
okay with this story
can you braid together the three
storylines in such a way that
you create the idea of a continuing rise
in
intensity narratively
and sustaining that is the challenge
of the structure and the way in which i
approach
different or complex structures as i
have in the past
um and and i do with this film is you
diagram it you you get a hold of it
mathematically so you know exactly what
it's meant to be doing
but then you sit down and you write the
script from page one right through to
the end of the film
the way the audience is going to be
receiving that information the hope is
that in that way
you're actually creating a cohesive and
organic rhythm and story movement
built on a very uh
constructed you know set of of
parameters but not through
cutting and pasting not creating a
fractured narrative so much as
disparate story threads that braid
together to make one you know coherent
story
i'm a self-taught filmmaker i never went
to film school i never
studied filmmaking in any way i started
making films
uh when i was a kid when i was i think
seven years old uh
making films using my dad's super eight
camera and little action figures doing
stop-motion films a little bit of
animation and a certain amount of live
action
and i just carried on making films as i
grew up
and over the years they got bigger
hopefully better but but more elaborate
and there never really was a period of
my life where i completely stopped doing
that so i was always
moving up eventually from super 8 to 16
millimeter films and then
i think what following represents is
kind of the uh
the peak of what i was able to do on my
own or just with friends
uh just using our own resources and
borrowing equipment and
sort of using the things around us to
make a film i mean for me
the only sincerity in filmmaking is to
make a film
that you would want to go see yourself
and not treat the audience as anything
separate from from
from you our expectations when we go to
see a film
are different in different genres and at
different budget levels and that doesn't
mean we're
dumber when we go see a bigger film or
you know but we do have a different
expectations
it's a different register of language in
a sense
i mean i think it i think it was stanley
kubrick who said
the best way to learn how to make a film
is to make a film
and i certainly found that to be the
case um
i didn't go to film school and i just
i've always made my own films i started
at a young age
and when you're doing films just with
friends with no money
you know on a shoestring you have to be
able to do all the jobs
because when we made following for
example um
we were just shooting on saturdays we
all had jobs
in the week and so not everybody would
turn up and sometimes you'd be recording
sound and sometimes you'd be shooting
the film and
uh you know you really had to know a bit
of everything because you didn't quite
know
you know who your crew was going to be
on on the day and and it's a wonderful
way to learn everything and
and the larger the films have become i
think the more i've
been able to appreciate the learning
that i did
by doing and i know enough about every
job on set
to sort of be a pain in the ass to
everybody
you know just enough to not say i can do
your job but just to give them an idea
that i'm paying attention to what
they're doing and that i'm asking for a
particular
approach and it gives you confidence as
a filmmaker
i recommend it to any young filmmaker
starting out it's just try everything
try recording sound try shooting try
lighting you know try a bit of
everything
uh except maybe acting but um
but if you can get your head around all
those different disciplines
uh you don't feel quite so at the mercy
of your crew and there's an interesting
relationship as a director between
yourself and the people who
who work for you on set uh which is
they're looking to you for leadership
and
guidance and i think they also want to
feel like you care about their job and i
think one of the ways of showing
somebody that you care about their job
you know is to know about and be able to
engage in a conversation with
the sound department about microphones
and which microphones they're using and
things like that
i've always found dreams to be uh a
very inspiring uh part of my life
i think the the idea that has always
fascinated me about dreams is the
realization that everything within that
dream
is created by your own mind as you
experience it
and it's that peculiar relationship
between the creative part of
imagining a world imagining someone
talking to you
and then the realization that as you
absorb that world you're not aware of
the fact that you've actually created it
so if you're talking to somebody in a
dream you're supplying both halves of
that
that conversation but you seem to be
experiencing just from one half
and i think that what that says about
the
potential of the human mind is quite
extraordinary and inception is intended
to be a film that
that tries to explore the exciting
possibilities of what that says about
the human mind and the infinite
potential of the human mind it wasn't
conscious on my part to
to have another script sort of ready to
go by the time we
went to film festivals with following uh
while we were
finishing up the cut on it and doing
very long slow technical finishing which
when you have no money takes forever
because you're sort of waiting for the
lab to
have a you know run the 16mm bath you
know whatever it is
um in that time i was putting together
the script
for momentum and so also in the time it
took to get
following noticed on the festival
circuit so get out there i had actually
finished the script and in retrospect
it was a massive advantage because it
was able to say okay you like that film
this is what i want to do next because
in your best case scenario of what can
happen to you with
with putting a film out there and
getting distribution for example
um you're then asked the question okay
what do you want to do next
if you have an answer you can use that
very short window of interest that you
get from people in what you've done
i've always loved the spy genre i grew
up watching the james bond films and
uh you know later on the bourne films
and
you know the john le carre and all these
these great
um representations of espionage in
fiction and
the uh escapist component to that i
think is a big part of that
for me cinematically what the spy film
always allowed was
the idea of international travel the
idea of the glamour being able to go
places in the cinema that you'd never be
able to go in real life
and have access to all kinds of
extraordinary situations that you get to
enjoy by by proxy
and that's very much what we tried to
bring to tenet but we tried to do it
with an added science fiction component
we try to do it with
um a concept that would allow audiences
to approach this in a fresh way
for me tennet really is about taking the
uh
the elements of of spy fiction and and
particularly cinematic you know spy
fiction
and having it having new reason to look
at them in a different way taking them
and turning them on their heads really
do you ever come up with ideas
when you're writing a script that even
scare you in terms of not being able to
pull it off
uh yeah i mean the really that's the
challenge i mean as a writer
i try and take my director's hat off and
not be afraid and just say
i want to write the most exciting thing
the most unexpected thing i can think of
for the story
and then i pick up the script again and
put the director's hat back on and go
okay how the hell am i going to do that
and that's when you know you're in a
good place because every film you want
to be challenging yourself you want to
do something different
you